[Music]
what's up guys so we have deliberated we
were looking at new ways that you guys
can interact with us and we saw all the
offerings out there and we felt that we
can bring something unique and different
to this space so in welcoming you to the
realm I will allow you to get a peek at
what's affordable in each tier we have
the $4.99 tear the $7.99 tier and the
$14.99 and that's bronze silver and gold
tears alright and you get custom badges
emojis in the bronze tier the silver
tier and the gold tier in the gold and
silver tier you get behind-the-scenes
access to limited content in the silver
tier and the Gold's here you get full
access to behind-the-scenes bloopers
shows that we went to with videos that
we didn't put up early access to king of
the statues and early access to a lot of
articles that's on log neck modes of
game we've got netlog net that's what we
call it so these custom badges that you
get as some of the realms funniest
sayings like bend the knee for full
Dominus Maximus Spencer or the roam in
the bushes and especially you need to
have the fraud alert on deck where
people are fraud in in the chat so you
can throw up their floor to learn
you know we have a patreon but we felt
that this also gives you a level of
interactivity then we felt that you guys
deserved so oh also and the silver and
the gold tears you get discounts on the
merchandise at our teas from stores like
throw them in the bushes and other ILP
stuff like our famous logos you see or
[Music]
the IOP hat so no matter how you choose
to show your loyalty to the realm
everything is always appreciated now you
start off as a farmer and you work your
way up through the months till you
become an official Lord and your avatar
will change in each month and you too
can become a lord we greatly appreciate
your time your effort and
[Music]
as part of the Iowas team we couldn't
wait to get this stuff to you so this is
king david OTW the lord of the realm I'm
happy to have you guys aboard and I
cannot wait let's see what you guys do
with these emojis by the way during the
coming months more emojis and more
badges will be added so you're just not
limited to what you have there the more
people sign off the more emojis and more
badges helped us get that million
millions up see you guys later
can't wait to see you guys running wild
in that chat
[Music]